if I have it right where you either
offered the movie The Whale or there was
a discussion about you starring in the
movie The well that would have been the
role of a lifetime no well here's the
thing with that it was a very long time
ago and it was a completely different uh
Tom Ford had read the script and really
liked it and he sent me an email one day
and he was like I think I'm gonna direct
this film and I'd like to play this part
in truth I was like ah
this is a this I mean it's a it's a in
every sense a heavy role you know yeah
and it is a it is a it's an
extraordinary script and so look I was
like firstly I just sort of couldn't
believe that Tom Ford who is an
incredible director so I was like look
if if you think I can do this I'll do it
and then Tom dropped out of the film for
different reasons did he call you and
say I'm dropping out of this thing we're
not gonna yeah yeah he said look I'm not
disappointed he's like look
well it never got far enough to be close
enough to be like this is happening it's
not like there were dates or casts
attached or a rewrite had happened it
was so far away from happening that
things like that happen all the time
that's why I say like the film that
Darren made with Brendan Fraser is
absolutely the film that that should be
and I think that Brandon Fraser story is
the most
uplifting an extraordinary story
what he has done there like George in
the jungle and The Mummy and then to
just like come back and win every pretty
much every best actor award he's
nominated for if that doesn't give you
hope that anything is possible nothing
will